Now we're ready for
the matching equivalent of
the max flow min cut theorem.
The Max-MAtching/ Min
Vertex Cover Theorem.
Consider a bipartite graph G and
a matching M.
Then the following are equivalent.
M is a maximum matching.
M admits no augmenting paths and
there's a vertex cover That has the same
size as the size of the matching.
The proof will be very similar
to the max flow min cut theorem.
First we'll show that
if M is a max-matching,
then it can't admit
any augmenting paths.
Well suppose not.
Then there is some augmenting path,
and if we augment M by this path,
we get a larger matching, meaning that
M was not a maximum as we had supposed.
Next we argue that if M
admits no augmenting paths,
then there exists a vertex cover
that has the same size as M.
This is the most interesting
part of the proof.
We'll let H be the set of vertices
reachable via an alternating path
from unmatched vertices in L.
We can visualize this definition by
starting with some unmatched vertices in
L, then following its outgoing
edges to some elements in R, and
then following all the matched edges
back to matched elements of L,
and back and forth and so
forth, as many times as we can.
Note that because the matching
doesn't admit any augmenting paths,
all of these paths must terminate in
some matched vertex on the L side.
Let's draw the rest of
the graph here as well.
We have some matched vertices in L, the
vertices of R that they're matched to,
And possibly some unmatched
vertices in R as well.
Note that H and the compliment of
H correspond to the minimum cut
that we used when discussing
the max-flow min-cut theorem.
To get a min vertex cover,
we select the part of H that is in R and
the part of L that is not,
and we call this set S.
S contains exactly one
vertex of each edge in M.
If the edge in M happens to belong to H,
then we've got its right side.
And if it doesn't belong to H,
then we got its left side.
So the size of S and
the size of M must be the same.
Next, we need to convince ourselves
that S is really a vertex cover.
Remember that there are no edges
internal to R or internal to L, so
we don't need to worry about those.
The part of S that is in R covers
all the edges internal to our H
set of vertices, and
these over here in L,
they cover all edges in
the not H part of the graph.
So what we really need to worry about
are just edges that go across the cut.
Well, from here to here,
both vertices in the edge are covered.
So we really only need to worry
about the part of L that is in H
being one vertex, and the part of R
that is not in H being the other.
But if there were such an edge,
crossing here.
It would have been in H,
because we would have been going from
a vertex in H via
an unmatched edge to R.
We conclude there are no such edges,
and hence S is a vertex cover.
Finally we have to prove that
the existence of a vertex cover
that is the same size as a matching,
implies that the matching is a maximum.
And this follows immediately from
our discussion that a vertex cover
is an upper bound on
the size of a matching.
So if it wasn't a maximum matching, then
the whole idea of vertex cover wouldn't
be an upper bound, as we argued already.